back in Britain after all the
complications the worry and fear 83 UK
nationals touched down at RAF Brize
Norton at last they're out of China and
away from the epicenter of the deadly
coronavirus amongst those on board was
James convey he and his wife were
stranded in the lockdown city of Wuhan
running out of supplies he shared his
journey with Sky News from the deserted
Airport in Wuhan to the moment he landed
back on British soil and it's been an
anguishing wait for the families of
these British nationals James's father
was overwhelmed to see his son return
home this was the first time they spoke
so where are you now he's still on the
plane by the look of it are you oh
you're on the boss are you okay so
you're ready to move up to the where or
soon right okay how long is it going to
take do you know okay okay well I hope
that part of the trip goes well how are
you feeling
but their ordeal doesn't stop here
a 180 mile coach journey north to
Merseyside medical staff dressed in full
protection whilst they head to NHS
accommodation on the world it was only
on Thursday night the health secretary
called a local MP who says this is the
ideal facility I think there were a
number of factors one that it's not in a
city center or in the center of a town
the second is that the hostel
accommodation separate to the hospital
and then of course in this part of the
northwest we have particular expertise
and so we've got the Royal Hospital in
Liverpool's very strong on
I'm viral you know treatments and so
forth should that be necessary which
hopefully won't be and also the School
of Tropical Medicine in Liverpool so
there's a lot of expertise locally there
were meant to be more than 83 passengers
on board the 11 hour flight back to the
UK but dozens are still stuck in China
all the group chats are I'm on whatsapp
Facebook all begging me to come home
everybody especially my mom and my mom
it's disgraceful it's just there's been
no help at all it's just been drips and
drops of information more than anything
and when you ask them questions on the
information they give you they can't
really elaborate on what they told you
this was a complicated operation and the
British government may schedule another
repatriation flight to bring back those
left behind but here for the next two
weeks whilst 83 people aren't in their
homes they will be relieved to be back
home in the UK